Let's look at the solution to
our cache incoherence quiz.
We had three cache and three cores.
Allocation that starts at zero and
then each core reads, increments, and
then writes to that memory location.
So the question is,
what's the final value we write here?
The correct behavior would be for
core zdero to do this, and
then it replaces this from its cache so
that core one reads A1 here.
Increments that writes A2,
and then core two reads that,
increments, and writes A3.
So this three here is a possible
answer if core zero happens
to replace this block that contains A
from it's cache before core one tries to
read it and then core one replaces
before core two reads it and so on.
In that case we get actually A three
here, which is the correct answer.
So let's see now if we can get two.
Well, if core zero does a replacement,
so
the memory location after
this actually contains A one.
Then core one does this but doesn't
replace the block from the cache.
Then core two will still see a one.
It will not see what core one produced.
Because core one keeps
it in it's own cache.
So core two here reads
one increments it and
then core two ends up writing a two so
this is a possible answer and
then we can get a one here by,
basically,
core zero delaying the replacement, and
then core one can fetch a zero as well.
Put a one there, but not replace until
later and that means that when core two
reads this, it gets a zero and then puts
a one here so this is also possible.
It is not possible for
core two to write a zero because what
it reads it will increment and write.
So for core two to produce a zero here,
it would need to read minus one.
Note that each of these cores is still
behaving as a correct unit processor so
zero is not possible.
Similarly, four is not possible because
for four to be produced here we
need to read a three and there is just
no way that two increments from zero can
produce a three here and similarly
more than four is not possible.
So the correct answers here are one,
two, and
three are possible at this point.